questo è giallo C'è un nuovo Rainbow
Friends
[Musica]
è uscito il secondo capitolo dei Rainbow
Friends i pupazzi cattivi ve li
ricordate i pupazzi Cattivissimo il
secondo gioco il continuo siamo super
curiosi di vedere com'è vediamo una
recensione ma poi mi raccomando lasciate
un bel mi piace Passat provate qualcosa
da mangiare qualcosa da bere mettete più
comodi iniziamo questa avventura gira
gira
siamo nella Foresta di notte stiamo
scappando forse
c'è anche la luna piena Dove stiamo
andando
sei andato a mangiare
chi è questo
[Musica]
misure di sicurezza distrutte che cosa
ci parlo qua E tu che stai facendo
quello valido
sono sicuro che sia solo la tua
immaginazione
Ecco perché non mi aiutate tutti a
trovare la luce SOS ogni parco a tema ne
ha uno
Ok Dove può essere la luce per salvarci
dai vostri Rainbow prezzo Questo è un
garage e c'è scritto non entrare e noi
ovviamente entreremo e grosso
c'è il pulsante in mano perché non ci
farà esplodere Adesso aiuto
Sarà divertente di shred Ok
vado a prendere gli altri pronti a
scappare di nuovo per non essere tritati
che dovremmo prendere la vittoria
continua che cosa fa ho tipo una scatola
No questa è la box Vedi per nascondersi
[Musica]
vediamo quindi mi ero anche dimenticata
Questa volta siamo in un parco
divertimenti Che figo e ovviamente
dobbiamo giocare a nascondino con il
rimborso altrimenti vediamo spappolati
troppo belli troppo esplorando qui si
può salire sopra Guarda Rita Wow che
figo Ho un'idea facciamo un gioco con
voi volete sapere che Rainbow Friends
siete voi allora lasciate un mi piace
sotto a questo video e l'ultima cifra
del vostro mi piace quindi quando
cliccherete mi piace apparirà un numero
ad esempio ehm
mille e quindi l'ultima cifra sarà lo
zero corrisponde al vostro personaggio
vi metto qua a fianco i personaggi
Rainbow Friends per scoprire che
personaggio siete
scriveteci poi nei commenti che
personaggio siete Ehi Aspetta un momento
che cos'è No forse qualcosa per
spareremo Friends
[Musica]
riporta nel Laser tag Plaza Ok andiamo a
trovare 25 lampadine
Hahaha
Non puoi rubare tutte le lampadine che
trovo io Wow che figata
vedere tutte le regole per divertimento
[Musica]
è qua con la testa di blu gigante pure
io sto sulla zipline Ciao Qua non si può
affrontare però purtroppo
[Musica]
lo vedi e qui guarda No Come no Non lo
vedo soltanto
questa attrazione Ehi qualcuno la
facciamo partire
sta partendo
forse qua non ci vede sta provando a
prenderci ma non si vede
Io sono partito
[Musica]
devi aspettare Siediti 321
parte il perché non parte Aspetta
aspetta
[Musica]
tutte le lampadine etichetta laser va
bene non funziona
Ehi ma dice che abbiamo trovato Zero di
25 lampadine ma io ne ho raccolte un
sacco vero Ah perché dobbiamo ancora
metterle
Ok
Qua c'è il verde Qui c'è una caverna
aiuto
Ehi possiamo anche salire nella ruota
panoramica
dove sono tutte le lampadine Sì io sono
sulla ruota panoramica pure tu Wow che
bello vedere tutto il parco e io ho fame
dove c'erano le altre lampadine forse
qua nel castello ribassate Castelnuovo
Eccone un'altra Evviva Eh non mi puoi
prendere tutte le lampadine Eh ma tu
quante ne hai Io ne ho 6 io 7 Wow Qua
c'è un ponte laggiù c'è Orange Che
carino Qual è il vostro Rainbow Friends
preferito il mio forse Orange è più
carino sembra un coccodrillo che carino
Sì è troppo carino Orange però a me
piace anche verde perché è un po' un po'
salato
muove tutto e poi si stritola con le
braccia Ah Ah Aiuto Ho trovato verde
scappare
Non mi ha preso però
ci è mancato poco Era in una stanza qui
dove c'era scritto en flowers only solo
solo dipendenti Ecco altre lampadine Io
ne ho 10 veramente me dove le trovi
tutte queste lampadine dice che non
posso portare altri oggetti devi
[Applauso]
devo riportare le lampadine in quel
posto là ma non mi ricordo vera quel
posto cioè come faccio a tornare
dall'inizio per rimettere le lampadine
Forse era questo io non me lo ricordo
era all'inizio Sei sicuro farmi
compagnia
[Musica]
aiuto ci hanno bloccato no verde blu
oltre alla lampadina Laser tag Plaza
non lo sapevo mi
Devo nascondere si è bloccato blu si è
bloccato Spero che non mi veda
Oh c'è blu OK Provo a toccare il posto
dove mettere le lampadine
Tu dove sei anche io qua ho questa
etichetta laser quindi stiamo vicini
qui non ne sono sicuro
[Musica]
l'ospedale
Ecco L'ho trovato finalmente
figo ok Hai capito Sì ok Stiamo vicini
adesso non ci separiamo più piccolo
prezzo Dove andiamo adesso dove vanno
messe queste lampadine
Sei riuscita a dire come se sei riuscita
fuori dal Laser tag E allora dove vanno
messe Non ho capito
ok Ho messo le lampadine dovete mettere
qua fighissimo non l'avevo capito
scendi giù lì eh Eccoci Ok non ci
separiamo Mi raccomando vai a mangiare
qua
Controlla se ci sono altre lampadine Ok
ciao ciao
ah ah Porco Dio sto scappando no Tu dove
sei finito dall'altra parte io non sono
andato avanti ci avevo troppa paura
Wow che figata Ci sono anche le
macchinine per correre Io voglio correre
con la macchinina Wow
vediamo se c'è qualche lampadina qua in
questo posto qui si può correre con le
macchinine dopo non c'è niente uffa
allora torno di là Speriamo di
incontrarvi Ah ecco mi fa mi appare
l'immagine di dov'è la lampadina laggiù
in fondo Anch'io ne ho tre e con questa
forse anche quattro no al piano di sotto
questa però Uh uh uh uh uh uh Vitale ti
ho visto ti ha preso lui ha preso blu no
ti ho visto che ti sei sbracellato ho
visto le mani innate Poverino attenta
che è là vicino Eh ma ora non puoi
rinascere ma sono io
In generale sì dai rigenerati
per rigenerarmi eh
[Musica]
Devo solo fare in modo adesso che non mi
piace Devi solo ritornare indietro
adesso vai Vediamo le lampadine cosa
succederà adesso
ce l'hai fatta
superato il primo livello Ah hai
illuminato il blu Ecco il vecchietto di
prima in realtà c'era una luce SOS
voglio dire Wow voi ragazzi dovete
essere bravi a non ho fatto in tempo
reale ho detto C'è un mostro c'è blu c'è
scritto blu Sì è lui Oh no
è un po' lento questo vecchietto
è stato un errore Dobbiamo trovare una
via d'uscita E certo che dobbiamo
trovare una via d'uscita prego forse
questo può aiutarci a scappare da qui è
una macchina a forma di razzo
sarà scappare
c'è un nuovo Rainbow Friends
Yellow Immagino che ti chiama perché
giallo Guarda che ho deciso di
presentarsi
sono sorpreso che abbia superato la
paura del palcoscenico
Vitale è stato eliminato ma io non ce la
farò mai da solo a fare tutto Cioè che
cosa devo fare adesso Allora cannelli di
gas trovati Devo trovarmi quindi devi
trovare il gas per far andare per far
correre il razzo Eccolo qui
questo vitale per gli altri giocatori
cioè
Allora Vitale anche se non sei nel gioco
mi devi aiutare devi capire se ci sono
Rainbow Friends nelle vicinanze
[Musica]
Oh no sembra una trappola questa mi
nascondono la scatola
avete visto è passato lì Sì è là fuori
blu lo vedete questo nascondino è molto
pauroso
fuori l'importante è che non se ne
accorga lui sì forse abbiamo scampato Il
Pericolo vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro
qua
puoi fare tutto da sola
Ok quante ne mancano e te ne mancano
ancora al 10
e ce n'è una dietro non l'hai vista vai
[Musica]
Dai dai dai dai dai
È abbastanza facile
per ora allora
un uccello a forma di dinosauro
Infatti ha
le ali ma funziona aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto Non
so se nascondermi nella scatola ma ho
paura che mi trovi lo stesso Forse è
meglio scappare
Aiuto Che ansia questo gioco Spero che
non entri qua
no ok via libera però adesso devo stare
[Musica]
Ok vedo qualsiasi cosa di giallo e ho
paura te ne mancano ancora 5 ce n'è uno
solo
avanti
no no no no non mi sono spaventato
tantissimo
[Musica]
Adesso sì che c'è il giallo
vai via
e ancora dietro
potrebbe essere pericoloso Tieniti
pronto con la b perché per nasconderti
non si può entrare Lì si che si può
entrare te l'ho detto non mi sta
pensando vero
No
perché Lascia perdere adesso qui Oh
no posso credere guarda
che fa venire ansia ansia
[Musica]
posto assicurare
forza Ma quello era un posto sicuro Eh
ragazzi Ok mi sono rigenerata almeno ma
devo ancora mi ha tolto quelli che
dovevo mettere qua
OK riproviamo fai non riuscirete a
sconfiggermi tipo
Allora ce n'è uno là sopra e c'è anche
blu là sopra quindi stai attenta vediamo
Proviamo a passare da qua
perché non sia pratica e perché non
salta questo personaggio è inutile eh
l'hai chiusa quella porta
Che figo passaggio segreto questo mi
devo nascondere il Credo di sì no no no
no no no no no no
aspetta aspetta
non saltare non saltare Sì ma dove dove
devo saltare Qual è il trovo un posto
morto un albero
oppure in acqua dove devo saltare
aiuto figo puoi saltare da sopra non
credo nel nido No nel nido è meglio di
no perché ti mangia
Frozen mi ha mangiato ok Ragazzi abbiamo
deciso di ricominciare con altri
giocatori non ci riusciamo ma nel
frattempo vogliamo dirvi una cosa
importante che nel canale di vitale è
uscito un bellissimo video in cui fanno
un Escape Room non noi due ma Merlino
è super divertente bene mettiamo un
pezzettino qua così vedete quanto è
divertente il video mi raccomando dopo
questo video andate a vederlo e se
arrivate da questo video
Scrivetemi nei commenti la parola
segreta gelato al cioccolato andate a
scriverlo in quel video che ti sapremo
che voi siete arrivati da qua sapete la
parola segreta vi lascio la casellina in
cui vedere il video alla fine di questo
video ma ora pronti e ricominciamo
l'avventura insieme ad altri giocatori
che Ok speriamo che ci aiuteranno un
sacco loro Dobbiamo prendere tutte le
lampadine che troviamo ma ormai siamo
esperti
qualcuno è stato già trovato
Nomadi Già Uffa e che bello Non dobbiamo
per forza cercarle velocissimamente
perché tanto anche gli altri le stanno
cercando attento C'è blu
e qua in giro Ho trovato la lampadina
[Musica]
forse qua non può entrare però Sì si è
bloccato Meno male ok sta andando via
ora Arrivo subito ad aiutarvi appena blu
mi lascio in pace Chissà se riusciremo a
vincere il gioco adesso Grazie anche
agli altri giocatori ho trovato un posto
nuovo È tipo un labirinto segreto con
con degli occhiali
che fanno paurissima degli occhioni
gialli che escono da da dentro una siepe
forse il labirinto di Yellow allora
Potrebbe
il diritto di blu c'era blu dentro Io ho
trovato due lampadine
no
perde mi ha stritolato
[Musica]
ci sono lampadine le ultime parole
famose questa volta faremo più in fretta
ci sono anche gli altri
allora se qualcuno vuole le lampadine in
mano qui
Beh ma sono difficilissimo da trovare no
mi ha preso blu sei stato preso prova
farina ad essere dai
Guardate manca solo una lampadina della
giù illuminata la vedete vado subito
Tieniti pronto a mettere il fuoco si
blocca ogni tanto si blocca il mio
personaggio che succede
c'è blu lì che sta scappando ma quello è
arancione l'hai visto ancora
Ehi ma non Mettetevi in costume solo io
penso che siete loro è stato un errore
Ok mi nascondo anch'io Allora visto che
vi state nascondendo tutto
Che figo Io non vedo l'ora di farvi
vedere questa macchina come funziona e
riusciremo a scappare
Non ce la faremo mai Topolino io forse
sì dai possiamo riuscirci Ecco già uno
di questi
almeno non sono io da sola prima io da
sola ed era difficilissimo da sola
almeno questi sono solo 15-125 vai anche
prima erano 15 comunque venite venite
quanti siete rimasti
[Musica]
là sotto tra l'altro è il più terribile
giallo perché ti porta in giro ti fa
volare poi ti spiaccica Forse è meglio
se vado già a portarli già prese quattro
Dove devo qua giusto Sì
non te lo ricordi neanche tu vai Stai
andando benissimo
Allora secondo me qua non le troverai le
cose di gas perché c'è l'acqua e secondo
me l'acqua col gas non va bene scendi
giù vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua c'è
un'altra persona mi avrebbe già presi
Serena qua ad abbassarti a passare sotto
la caverna Magari nella caverna si trova
del gas
lì non sono nascondiglio Allora prova a
salire qua sul ponticello che l'altra
volta sul ponticello l'avevi trovata
verde però verde È troppo forte
troppo ridere come si muove quindi il
tuo preferito è verde il mio Orange
Invece quello che odio di più finora
Yellow E certo ci credo ti sfracella
sulla roccia ogni volta che ti prende e
tu Qual è il tuo preferito il mio
preferito Yellow Sicuramente ma anche
blu eh Prima mi ha mangiato tutto
scrivete voi nei commenti Qual è il
vostro preferito invece quello che vi
sia piaciuto di tutti uso la zipline per
andare più veloce
Secondo me l'ha rotto Yellow lì
via Saliceto panoramica
fa prova a risalire con la zipline
[Musica]
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa forse c'era
uno in quella parte Viola hai visto
niente Allora vediamo se c'è qualcosa
qua Forse dopo si potrà entrare qua Ah
ah ah ah preferito
no lascia entrare lì
[Musica]
potevi entrare nella caverna e magari
era più sicuro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Chi è che sta sparando Oh vai avanti
aiuto
il castello entra lì nel castello che è
sicuro più o meno ancora mi sta seguendo
attentamente
nasconditi devi nasconderti nel box B B
B B
oh oh Per un pelo un secondo di distacco
che mi avrebbe girata ok Oh ti sei
salvata Per un pelo Ok assolutamente
portare una sola tanica di benzina
ancora non ne mancano 2 minuti
devo assolutamente andare a metterla
senza farmi Ah ah ah ah
ah
Per fortuna che ti ho aiutato Io e così
Infatti tu nascondimi quando ne ho
bisogno Aspetta devo mettere il braccio
qui però Ok vai
[Musica]
da questa porta
è giallo no no no no no no
ti ho visto Ti ho visto scappate entra
dalla porta dietro dalla porta adesso
nasconditi
no troppo tardi
che succede Oh non se n'è accorto però
venire un ansia Allora aspetta Ho
un'idea Aspetta un attimo questa porta
qui dove porta lì c'è la tanica di
benzina vedi
qualche parte lo vedi che ti esce in
sovrappeso Vai vai
devo andare a portare questa
Allora Guido mi troverò il posto in cui
portarla
stai andando nella direzione giusta Sei
sicuro a fette
bisco
Vai piano piano così bravissima
ok lui sta andando lì dove devo andare
io
Dai vai via blu ah ah no no no non ti ho
visto non ti ho visto non ti ho visto
Hahaha
Ok te la tolgo scappi Eh ok Vai via via
via via
no
mi sento di stare fermo
qua dentro Brava Ecco l'ultima è qua e
laggiù Sì più bello forza
correre a prenderlo forse su
Ma perché nessuno L'ha sorpresa ancora
questa è labirinto che ti dicevo prima
ti ricordi Wow che figo che figata
questo gioco È bellissimo Anche se fa
venire la sede è difficile Ci sono le
macchinine per correre I go kart Sì dopo
riproviamo
[Applauso]
Scusa mi sono fatto prendere dalla mamma
mamma
era l'ultima
Ah ok sono rinata però non ho più quella
cosa devo andare a riprenderla Ma
possibile che non ci siano altri
giocatori Quali sono gli altri giocatori
sono da sola Credo di sì Vediamo No
guarda
c'è qualcuno che mi sta inseguendo non
lo sento Sento rumore
MHM oppure sì
Allora qui c'è un giocatore vedi
Sì ma ce l'ho io qua adesso quindi devo
andare io la
responsabile
Marco grande
Speriamo che funzioni Ma come Speriamo
che fa funzionare
[Risate]
[Musica]
Ma che cosa sono partite delle teste di
Rainbow Friends le avete viste ma io mi
aspettavo che la macchina partisse come
un razzo infatti
che succede come ho fatto ad arrivare
quassù E non lo so
bene proviamo di nuovo ma vuole proprio
eliminarci Red
oh oh
Raccogli tutti quei lupi che hai appena
rilasciato E lascerò vivere il vecchio
oh
questa volta c'è un timer no c'è pure un
timer Guarda c'è qualcosa con i like Ma
non potete mettermi pure un timer siamo
rimasti in tre tre
[Musica]
però proviamoci Allora questo Come si
prende
che devi mettere qui dentro devi
raccogliere gli altri e metterli qui
dentro Oh mamma è difficile
amore blu qua Adesso dimmi quando vuoi
che metto il box
Ok preso uno ne potrò prendere un po'
alla volta non lo so ma no ne potrei
prendere anche altri attenta che c'è blu
lì no Che figo
tutti È bellissima no
è difficile Ehi come ti ha preso la
palla no no no no no no Ma come dici te
l'ha presa Ma allora come potete vedere
qua No Ehi ma ci siamo dimenticati che
c'è il timer
Poverino
quello che avevo preso prima è tornato
qua Ok andiamo a metterlo subito
brutta idea
[Musica]
No non ti vedo non ti vedo ma se ti
nascondi va via quello nuovo
fatto estremamente difficile ok
andiamo a prendere adesso ok
[Musica]
Vedi qua se c'è qualcosa
ma che cosa adesso da sotto terra
stavano uscendo ok Ho messo il giallo
adesso ne mancano solo
ne mancano troppo ce n'è un'altra prova
Vai Brava Anita sono quattro di dieci ne
mancano solo se sei
No sono stato preso siamo rimasti in tre
in un'altra Federica
cinque
nasconditi
Che fortuna
allontanati così col box che è meglio
[Musica]
7 di 10
fortissimo Forse ce la facciamo
Cos'era un rumore
ciao ciao ciao ciao no ti sta seguendo
no no no no no no
no no no
no
[Musica]
nascosta sott'acqua lì hai visto
Dove posso trovare lì siamo al
vecchietto
proviamo
ho atterrato nel castello aperta non ci
credo Come faccio per abbassarti e poi
vai ok
Bravi bravi bravi
è troppo difficile l'hanno fatto troppo
difficile
[Musica]
e un po' difficiletto Sì è molto più
difficile del primo
impatto
[Musica]
qua Forse sì non vedere manca solo una
te ne manca solo uno non ci credo
Dobbiamo farcela davvero
[Musica]
Spero che gli altri giocatori siano
bravi da trovarla anche loro se non
sbaglio era qua vicino
aiuto
che stavamo spingendo vediamo se riesco
a rinascere di nuovo
no no no no allora stai andando nella
direzione giusta però c'era giallo lì
che ti stava aspettando
Allora vediamo eh adesso a fare la testa
lì
[Applauso]
dici come mai non pensare che figo dai
dobbiamo finirlo dobbiamo finirlo Ok
per dove andare ok
[Musica]
dove devo andare dove era anche vero
Non lo so aiuto sì di qua tutto dritto
di là ok Vai sta scadendo il tempo
bel lavoro a tutti
è riuscito ad uscire Forse
siamo rimaste in due in due
non preoccuparti sto bene non c'è tempo
da perdere cioè il mio primo piano di
fuga è fallito ma c'è un altro modo per
uscire da qui
c'è una via d'uscita attraverso le
montagne russe arancioni Dobbiamo solo
trovare un modo per far muovere quella
testata Lucky Se solo potessimo trovare
un po' di torta anche detto farebbe di
tutto per una fetta di torta ma sono io
no
no non prego non mi dire che
cosa sta succedendo non ci credo
Oh no aspetta arrivo
Uffa però no siete in due anzi
non è giusto Ragazzi purtroppo si è
mancato il gioco ma se volete nel
prossimo video partiremo direttamente da
qua vi faremo vedere la fine ma solo se
lasciate un bel mi piace qua sotto e ora
vi lasciamo Qua quattro Caselle cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video
Buona visione Ciao